Depuis la nuit des temps...
... Qu'est-ce que tu fais Romain là ?
Romain: Je mange une banane !
...avec tes pieds ?
Vous avez sans doute entendu dire que l'Homme descend du singe.
Bah c'est faux !
Oui c'est faux parce qu'on a des origines communes avec eux,
mais en réalité les singes, c'est pas nos ancêtres
c'est nos frères, nos sœurs, nos cousins, nos cousines
On est juste des Primates, comme eux !
On fait partie de leur famille, celle des Hominidés
Bon allez, si vous refusez d'y croire, voilà 5 preuves qu'on est des animaux
La meilleure preuve qu'on est des animaux : on a une queue
Une toute petite, mais on a une queue
- Euh toute petite... Parle pour...
Oh non non
Dans l'utérus de nos mamans on a tous et toutes une queue quand on est à l'état d'embryon
Mais elle disparaît quand on devient des fœtus
Sauf des fois...
Et à la naissance on a encore un reste de ce qui a été notre queue
Elle est là, tout en bas de notre dos
Et on la voit pas de l'extérieur, normalement
Alors on va aller faire un petit tour à l'intérieur
Notre colonne vertébrale, comme son nom l'indique, c'est un empilement de vertèbres
Elle commence sous notre crâne avec les cervicales,
elle se prolonge par les dorsales
et elle se termine par les lombaires puis le sacrum
qui est le résultat de la soudure entre elles, de cinq vertèbres
qu'on appelle les "vertèbres sacrées"
Et pour finir il y a le coccyx
qui vient s'articuler sur le sacrum
Le coccyx c'est un petit bout d'os qui est lui aussi formé de 4 ou 5 vertèbres, soudées entre elles
qui est un petit peu en forme de bec d'oiseau
Et qui tient son nom de "coxus", le coucou
Coucou, tu veux voir ma.....
C'est ce qu'on appelle une structure vestigiale c'est-à-dire que c'est un vestige
de ce qui a été notre queue.
Mais comme aujourd'hui on n'a plus besoin d'une queue pour assurer notre équilibre
et qu'on a trouvé d'autre moyens pour chasser les mouches,
elle a disparu et il nous reste plus que ce petit souvenir.
Mais c'est pas tout !
C'est pas tout parce qu'un vestige de notre animalité
on en a aussi un qui se voit comme le nez au milieu de la figure sauf qu'il est caché
et qu'il n'est pas sur notre nez mais dans nos yeux.
Je sens que je vous ai perdu là..
Si vous regardez d'un peu plus près juste là au coin de votre œil
Bon... vous allez loucher.
Mais si vous regardez d'un peu plus près juste là, au coin de CET oeil,
Vous allez remarquer une petite membrane
C'est la Plica Semilunaris, un pli de la conjonctive,
qui est un vestige de la membrane nictitante, aussi appelée troisième paupière.
Chez un certain nombre d'animaux elle recouvre l’œil horizontalement pour le protéger ou le nettoyer
sans masquer la vue, puisqu'elle n'est pas opaque !
Chez les humains il en reste un petit bout, mais vraiment pas grand chose.
En même temps, depuis, là encore on a trouvé d'autres moyens de se protéger les yeux en y voyant clair quand même,
alors nique-ti-tante la membrane !
Mais c'est pas tout !
Au rayon des structures vestigiales on peut aussi citer les troisièmes molaires ou "dents de sagesse".
Elles sont là tout au fond de votre bouche, et si on vous les retire
c'est pas seulement parce qu'elles ont la fâcheuse habitude de se baigner les lendemains de soirée trop arrosés !
D'ailleurs on ne les retire plus systématiquement, mais seulement quand elles posent problème.
Et si elles sont les dernières à pousser, en réalité ça fait très longtemps qu'elles existent
parce qu'en des temps ancestraux elles servaient à mastiquer longuement et à broyer les aliments fibreux ou durs,
comme de la viande crue ou des végétaux.
Autant vous dire qu’aujourd’hui, chez la plupart des gens, elles servent plus à grand chose
À tel point qu'il semblerait qu'il y a de plus en plus d'enfants chez qui elles ne poussent plus !
Pour finir avec les structures vestigiales, on peux aussi citer les amygdales, dans le fond de votre gorge,
et l'appendice, dans le fond de votre... colon.
Vous avez remarqué, c'est que des trucs que les chirurgiens vous enlèvent sans que ça vous manque vraiment !
Mais c'est pas tout !
Y'a pas que des organes qu'on a gardé du temps où on était des bêtes, y'a des réflexes aussi.
Comme la chair de poule par exemple, ou plutôt la piloérection ou "horripilation".
Chez les animaux à forte pilosité, les muscles érecteurs du poil ou horripilateurs ont pour fonction de dresser les poils sur peau.
Ça a deux grandes utilités:
Quand il fait froid d'abord, ça permet au pelage d'emprisonner contre la peau une plus grande quantité d'air,
qui sert d'isolant thermique.
Et en cas de grosse frayeur, c'est à dire principalement en cas d'attaque d'un prédateur,
gonfler sa fourrure, ça rend l'animal plus impressionnant en augmentant son volume.
Et bien l'humain a gardé ces muscles érecteurs du poil, et le réflexe qui va avec.
Bon on est d'accord que dans les deux cas, ça nous sert assez peu au quotidien,
mais on l'a gardé.
"Cadeau, on vous le mets quand même !"
Mais c'est pas tout !
Bon ok, il y a quand même une différence entre nous et les autres animaux.
Un poney par exemple, il sait marcher quasiment dès sa naissance !
Alors que nous...
...alors que nous aussi figurez vous !
Grâce aux réflexes archaïques de la marche automatique,
un nouveau né humain est capable de marcher si on le tient sous les aisselles.
Il est même capable d'enjamber des obstacles !
Attention, ce n'est pas quelque chose que le bébé maîtrise.
Ça s'explique par le fait qu'à la naissance le système nerveux n'est pas complètement mature, et fonctionne essentiellement par réflexes,
comme celui-ci, ou le fait de téter ce qu'on lui mets dans la bouche.
Vers 3 ou 4 mois la partie du système nerveux responsable des mouvements volontaires est mature,
et le réflexe de marche automatique disparaît.
Il faut alors que le bébé réapprenne à marcher,
selon un schéma qui, d'après une étude italienne, utilise exactement la même chaîne de commande nerveuse
que celle des bébés rats, dans la même situation.
Vous voyez bien qu'on est des bestioles !
Et devinez quoi ?!
Bah cette fois c'est tout.
DTC c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui,
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo !
Continuez à me poser vos questions, je note TOUT, c'est promis !
Abonnez vous pour être surs de rien louper.
En attendant, gardez la pêche, et surtout,
Surtout !
Portez-vous bien.